hey everybody i was not planning on
streaming until later tonight because we
do have the david pakman show
chess tournament coming up later in fact
as you can maybe tell
i was um i was biking in fact and i was
wearing
a mask and gloves and a hazmat suit i
was wearing everything it was a complete
it was a perfect bike ride in fact i
would say given the situation
but um the white house very abruptly
scheduled a trump
uh press conference to take place in the
rose garden
um sitting a little high i'm gonna have
to adjust my shot that's interesting
i'll do that in a bit uh maybe i'll just
lower my chair let's see
there we go a little bit lower there
perfect um so i
am still planning on streaming at 8 pm
eastern tonight which is how long from
now is that
that is three hours and 16 minutes
because we do have the david pakman show
chess tournament you can
subscribe or register for free at
davidpakman.com
chess um but i am going to stream this
because
some i don't know what's up i mean if i
had to guess
it seems to me that listen a lot of
things are falling apart right now for
donald trump you've got
the republican convention in florida is
very much in question a bunch of
prominent republicans saying
they're not going it's not safe to go
florida is one of the worst places not
just in the united states but one of the
worst places
in the world to be right now oh let me
mute the chess
tab because people are trying to
challenge me right now which we're not
going
to do just register for the tournament
you can play against me tonight if
that's
if that's your your thing um you've got
you know the the republican national
convention was going to be in north
carolina north carolina said if you do
it here you're going to have to reduce
capacity
so they moved it to florida florida is
the epicenter of the outbreak along with
arizona right now with their growth
rates
so a bunch of republicans are saying i'm
not going to go so trump is now in this
position where
if he ends up canceling it he looks weak
if he
ends up doing it but it's a coronavirus
party
that looks bad and the other risk is he
does it
and people don't go because increa i
mean listen you can get a few thousand
people in a room
you could say you're going to be
torturing people and you'd have a few
thousand trump sycophants show up those
sick people
but you know maybe you can't really fill
the uh
venue size that donald trump is looking
for and the turnout could also be a
problem for donald trump so
that's going on trump is retweeting
the conspiratorial ideas of former game
show host
chuck woolery while saying fouchy is the
guy
that can't be trusted by the way we've
got a hype train going on twitch i just
saw that's beautiful beautiful thing
uh trump yesterday was asked about
testing
by our friend weijiya zhang from cbs
news she's a follower
of me and trump not only looked weird he
sort of muttered something about obama
and biden i mean just listen to this
president trump you've said many times
that the number of by the way nasty
question incoming get the kids out of
the room
coronavirus cases is going up because
testing is increasing that's right
do you acknowledge that it's going up
for other reasons too for example that
it's
actually spreading and what are you
going to do to stop
the spread right well you know that we
have one of the lowest mortality rates
anywhere so first of all we are ninth
highest le i'll just
fact check in real time if you go to
let's see here if you rank countries
by wait where'd the table go here it is
if you rank
by uh deaths per population
you will very quickly notice that out of
200
countries and territories the united
states is ninth highest okay
so when trump says lowest mortality it's
never clear where whether he means
case fatality rate or whatever you know
when trump says
we have a low mortality rate he may be
referring relative to testing but the
point is what portion of the population
is dying
we are ninth highest highest highest
ninth highest
okay let's continue if you know biden
and obama stopped their testing
biden and obama stopped their testing
is he talking about h1n1 is he talking
about ebola
where there were four cases and two
deaths like what how is that even an
answer
just stopped it you probably know that
i'm sure you don't want to report it
but they stopped testing right in the
middle they just went
no more testing and uh on a
much lesser problem than the problem
that we have so this is a guy who is
falling apart i mean he's disintegrating
before our very eyes
and so the whole point is i've been i've
been building slowly to a climax here
that
there was this very abruptly scheduled
press conference in the rose garden
um scheduled for just 12 minutes from
now we don't know anything about it
i don't know what is going to be said i
assume it will be
hyperbole combined with i mean you know
who knows what else
but uh we're here for it i wasn't
planning on streaming until later
because we've got the chess tournament
but
i am going to be covering it we do have
a hype train happening very powerfully
right now at twitch.tv slash david
pakman level two has been completed
and we are now on to level three and we
will see
what kind of progress is made there let
me address some of the
messages that are coming in by super
chat now if you're one of the 4 200
people currently watching on youtube
these messages in the lower left of the
screen that you see
can be sent to me via super chat and
a few of those messages include tony
spergen
asking when the phone lines will next
open tomorrow
12 15 pm eastern u.s time
tomorrow 12 15 pm eastern time
seth barham asks david where do you see
us as a country around september
if unemployment ends and evictions are
allowed to happen
in an even worse place from the
standpoint of trump getting elected you
know
the economist which is no liberal rag
oh sorry i froze there uh it's no
liberal rag as you know
doesn't believe the the election is
competitive anymore
they just put out uh a report about that
so uh we're going to have to watch it it
may get worse before it gets better
let's put it that way um
javi rodriguez says has any governor
botched coveted
more than desantis arguably not arguably
not
daniel krieger says i just freaking love
you man thanks daniel great to see you
chris n says how many tesla shares do
you own
um i don't i don't remember that but
i'm going to tell you guys something
very powerful i know many of you have
been following what's going on
with tesla or tesla as i like to
pronounce it and i've disclosed my stock
ownership
in tesla many many times before
let me just look it up um i i researched
today so tesla is now
trading at fifteen hundred dollars per
share i bought tesla
um on february 6th
of 2015 meaning the price on that day
february 6. let's take a look here
february 6
it was at right yeah 200 i bought it 206
dollars per share
it's now trading at 1 500. is it time to
sell
is it time to sell i have so many people
telling me david
you've got to sell those shares you've
got to get out
now as many of you might remember i did
sell half
when elon musk went on the joe rogan
program i think it was a couple years
ago
and smoked pot and investors went crazy
and then he tweeted that he was maybe
going to take the company private and
the sec was like yeah you can't just
tweet about that that's illegal
and this whole problem i sold half at
that point now i believe that that was
around
when was that i that was around maybe
four hundred dollars a share
in any case i have half of the shares i
bought in 2015
i still have at fifteen hundred dollars
a share
i don't ever really sell stocks that's
the thing
i my i am a warren buffett benjamin
graham type of investor
and which mostly means i believe i can't
really pick stocks and i just invest in
in mutual funds but i do have six or
seven percent
of my portfolio in some individual
stocks i've owned most of them for five
years
i bought amazon in february of 2015. i
bought netflix in february of 2015.
i bought siriusxm in february i bought
uh alphabet
in 2014 i think at the time it was
google
and i bought tesla those are really the
only ones i have and i just hold
indefinitely that's that's my approach
so
you know you guys tell me as if i'm
really going to listen to random people
on twitch
is it time for me to sell this tesla
stock
i don't know i don't know i think i'm
gonna hold
okay renholder57 says
please tell me he's resigning i doubt it
steve waterstone says keep speak
the truth no matter what situation thank
you from australia my pleasure
eric lam armed thank you for supporting
my work
pair tier end says hi y'all tyron
visiting my dear friends
very good diane marzoni says hey david
watching from tucson arizona i feel
sorry for you diane i have friends in
tucson and it is ugly there
because of the virus beautiful city i
appreciate what you do and love the show
what do you think about
elaine maxwell and the possibility of
her safety
you know i've talked about that a lot on
the show so i don't want to i don't want
to duplicate content
but certainly much much of that has been
discussed
let me say some thank yous on twitch
because we are in the middle
of a level four hype train with three
minutes to go
spaz 667 has signed up
the toothless sage has subscribed
um who else here young freud has
subscribed with the message i
sub very strongly
kaninens has subscribed walking pancake
is on month number seven
utopian gamer and folks like dm quinta
and i losing jane fool a lot of very
strong subscriptions happening over on
twitch
uh yeah no punished mutant today but i
do see you in the chat there
uh we are in the middle of a level four
hype train i still don't understand what
it means but i know it's good
i know it's very very good so that's uh
that's happening
if you are watching on youtube
uh i will remind you that i will be live
streaming
tonight 8 p.m eastern the david pakman
show
third ever chess tournament i'm selling
you nothing
only the opportunity to build community
with me
you can register for the tournament for
free at davidpakman.com
as you can see 243 people currently
registered
i'm selling it's just you can play in a
tournament that's all there's no there's
nothing on the tail end coming where i'm
going to try to sell you something
um i invite you to play and i'll be
streaming my participation if you'd
rather just watch me play you can do
that
at 8pm i'll be doing this stream then
i'm gonna make some
beautiful tacos and uh i'll i'll then
start streaming probably about 20 of and
then a
major announcement i have been invited
uh by grand master
wait for it uh hikaru nakamura
to be one of 16 participants
in pog champs 2 scheduled for late
august
okay i have been invited that's what i'm
supposed to say so far
pending any formal announcements um
my first i will be coached by actually
can i say
i'm i'm not going to say who let me i'm
not going to say who i'm being code i
have two coaches
a man and a woman both excellent chess
players
the first training will be tomorrow
night 8 30 pm eastern
and that will be with the gentleman who
will be coaching me
next week i will be probably doing a
stream
with the young lady who will be coaching
me and i am lucky that two of
the premier not just chess players but
two of the premier chess streamers
okay are going to be coaching me in this
tournament and it's going to be
amazing it's going to be amazing so
we've got a lot i mean really we've got
a lot of great stuff happening
over the next six weeks that hopefully
will give us
a respite from the horrible failed
leadership that we're experiencing here
in the united states so i think it's
going to be really great
other super chats coming in waffles
giroffel says i'm acing watching this
stream totally shocked yeah
doctors were shocked by how well donald
trump was able to watch tv they'd never
seen anybody do that before
and sean m says david warren buffett
annually auctions off
a private lunch to raise money for
charity would you do something similar
for your supporters
um you know i'd have to think about how
much it's likely to raise
because that's a lot of work that's a
lot of work and i'd have to i'd have to
think about
that we are on a level five hype train
with two and a half minutes to go people
like jay ramsey
have subscribed with messages like the
david pakman show is the only reason i
have a twitch account
that's a powerful statement uh subwoof
plays games says you rock david
stefan rowe is in for eight months and
we are getting dangerously close to
completing today's
hype train um what else did i have to
show you
oh listen i i don't a lot of people
have not not seen this about a year and
a half ago
the westboro baptist church went and
protested
in richmond virginia and it just so
happens that one of our
key team members noah producer noah
lives in richmond virginia so we sent
noah to talk to the westboro baptist
church this is really interesting video
this is sort of buried on our on our
youtube
channel but somebody mentioned it to me
and i thought i would show it to you
guys
this is so funny where you're gonna see
shirley phelps roper here who i've
interviewed
police are sort of keeping people away
from her but as soon as noah mentions
the david pakman show
shirley becomes interested in talking to
him i actually think she might have
thought
noah was david pakman but that's just
confusion take a listen to this
do you want to talk to the david backman
[Music]
she turns off we know each other it's
cool
yeah many times we haven't had you on in
a while have you would you be willing to
come back on
what are you out here protesting today
jesus christ several things but mostly
[Applause]
and it's on full display out here just
look around
that's really that's really interesting
do you still think david pakman is going
to hell
except they repent everyone will go to
hell is everyone in david pakman's
audience going to hell you have you have
taken this subgroup of sodomites called
transgender right and elevated it again
with lightning speed to a position of
respect
in this country what god has called an
abomination
and you said you would be willing to
come back on our show
what do you think you guys would want to
talk about if you came back on
whatever he always has something to talk
about the only thing i'll be talking
about is the word of god
anyway so isn't it great that they've
kind of disappeared i think it's a very
very good thing that nobody's really
talking about them anymore and
certainly i won't be rehabilitating them
that's for sure but it does seem
it wasn't clear whether she thought i
was going to hell because i'm jewish or
because i'm a sodomite or because i'm
transgender or what it's really weird i
mean
and of course i'm not but it was really
bizarre
um we are just minutes away from a very
abruptly spa if you're just joining us
because it is the top of the hour
um and the event was scheduled to start
this was a very abruptly scheduled press
conference by donald trump
we don't know what to expect and um the
the i'm i'm guessing many of you i think
we have ten thousand people watching
right now what the hell is going on here
hold on a second is that could that be
possibly be real are 10 000 people
watching right now
two nine 11 000 people are watching this
this is insane
i don't know that i've ever had i think
12 000 is the most people i've ever had
watch a stream that's crazy
i maybe some of the of you 12 000 people
know what to expect i don't know but
what we know is that donald trump's
polling is in the toilet
donald trump's cognition is in the trash
uh the economist says that this election
is no longer competitive
so we don't know what is going on um
but i mean i'm not even going to
speculate i'm just going to
wait and see uh what it is that is uh
that that we are to expect here
um okay let me mention oh so here's one
thing i've been limiting my membership
pitches to one minute during these
streams
and it's been working unbelievably and
people write to me and they say david
it seems the less you talk about
membership the more people sign up so
give me that one minute right now this
is viewer supported media
we have staff we have a studio we
you know people have health insurance i
try to be a good employer
we're we're starting to look into
retirement plans for our staff
i try to be one of the good guys all of
it really is funded
primarily by people who just sign up on
my website joinedpakman.com
we had at the beginning of july a big
hole to dig
out of in terms of memberships about 300
people were not able to renew their
memberships
because of the virus and that's horrible
um and we're going to keep doing the
show and the show is for everybody
if you can help us dig out of that
300-member hole a little bit
i would love it and you can grab a
membership at joinedpakman.com
i think on monday yesterday we dug out
about 17 members worth
and last week we dug out about 70
members worth so we're
we're making some progress you can use
that coupon code if you want
20 20 now it'll save you 66
it's not means tested it's just do what
you want
um and if you pay for the year using
that code it's like a dollar 83 a month
which i think is is
eminently reasonable from the standpoint
of
content so by all means feel free to do
that
a couple of people who just did are
anthony luchan
who is new member number one today lisa
h
is new member number two and nicholas
mitchell
is new member number three which uh i
love
and very very much appreciate as we
stand by here
for donald trump scheduled for a few
minutes ago it looks like that's cnn's
jim acosta
ready to do a little pre-event uh
briefing i guess to the cnn audience
which hopefully suggests that things are
going to be happening
very soon and very powerfully um if i
see people confused about whether
this is the chess tournament no the
chess tournament is at 8pm tonight east
8pm eastern
this is an impromptu stream i just got
back from biking
i'm wearing athletic shorts if you can
imagine something more vile
and this was a very abruptly announced
press conference
we don't know what is going on but it
was very abruptly and urgently announced
media was gathered we're not sure what
to expect or who's going to be here
trump increasingly at war with dr
anthony fauci
trump's polling in the toilet this
morning they had this try something new
campaign where they're basically saying
if you've lost your job
go and look for work in a different
field which is absolutely and completely
insane
so we're all waiting together but the
chess tournament will be tonight
you can register at davidpakman.com
chess as you can see here we have 251
players
registered um i am going to be playing
i'll be streaming
and we have one two three we've got
seven players
rated 2000 or higher but at the same
time we have people
in the 600s and the 800s it's really
just for fun
that's all it is you don't have to you
know it's just for fun and i look
forward to seeing
a whole bunch of you find folks there
later
uh we right now have a record 144 people
browsing our website at the same time
many of them on the membership page
i don't know what it is about what's
going on today but we are now
at like 13 000 live concurrent viewers
this is the most people i've ever had
watch any of my streams this is insane i
have no idea what's going on
9 300 on youtube 2200 on facebook
1700 on twitch some people are watching
on
i i have no idea what is going on right
now
but i guess we all want to see what it
is donald trump is about to say
unbelievable okay um
for whatever reason my super chats have
not
updated let me just black that out for a
second
and refresh i think i know what might
have happened
because i see that super chats are
coming in but they're not actually
showing up
let me see here
i want to make sure that i see super
chats
ah here we go we got them back very good
there they are okay
so let me see where i left off um
i don't even see wow there's so many
collected maxwell
acing okay zachary foster says trump is
now saying covid
data needs to be collected by the
national guard
i didn't see that i didn't see that good
vaccine news i didn't see the vaccine
news either so let me see if i can find
that i've been trying to keep up with
what's going on with vaccination
let's see vaccine
moderna to begin final human trial at
the end of july
that is very good news that's very good
news i'll dig into that probably on the
show tomorrow
we have just broached 10 000 live
viewers on youtube alone i think the
only time that happened was once when i
was about to broadcast the debate and
cnn shut me down they pinched off the
entire stream
um and that's happening right now which
is great
unknown prodigy says david you have got
to sell those shares you have got to get
out of your tesla stock seriously sell
okay chrisen says please take this money
and buy 1
100 of a tesla share karen altman
and psycho jet black sends super chats
psycho jet blacks has thoughts on
neo-liberalism versus corporatism
that's more of a topic for like a long
form video not so
much for a live stream but a very
important topic for sure
luke says fyi in addition to these
weekly super chats i'm also a subscriber
on your website keep up the great work
david hashtag not trump 2020 that i
agree with
karen altman says has anyone heard
anything about bolsonaro is he still
saying kavit
isn't a problem i mean he has it and
he's taking hydroxy
who knows what he believes at this point
sean says sell
even if it goes to two thousand dollars
a share you'll still make more than two
times the original price
elon will kill the company at some point
a lot of pessimism about tesla stock
vegas nightshade says can't wait till
tomorrow definitely will join
danny thompson says if you paid 200 a
share for tesla and sold half for 400
you've made back your original
investment right my advice
would be to hold for a while why not if
it is all profit
interesting advice mike says thank you
for your reporting what scheme do you
anticipate trump and bard to queue up as
they attempt to remain in power after
the election
i actually am addressing that in detail
on friday i'm addressing that on friday
so that's going to be huge nikki party
has subscribed on twitch and says notice
me senpai
notice me you've been noticed nikki you
are subscriber number 515
over on twitch uh jim acosta from cnn
is now live on cnn which i think
means they've hopefully been given the
two-minute warning that trump is coming
out
we're all i don't know what to expect um
but it
it could be anything this was a very
abruptly scheduled press conference with
donald trump
and um we have 11
13 and a half 15 000 people watching
along with me right now which i very
much appreciate waiting to see
i have no prediction i have no
prediction for what we are expecting to
see today
but um i i it's anybody's guess
thank you to my good friend i'm
inconsolable
who has just gifted 20 subscriptions
on twitch i'm inconsolable
is the top gifter ever on my
twitch channel and i don't know exactly
how many he's uh gifted but
it's it's certainly in the hundreds
certainly in the hundreds
says david keep the streams coming stay
strongly paratiran says wow you getting
around
gesh make says much of what trump says
is an exaggeration yeah that's true
i am confident if he and or his
administration are considering this an
emergency be prepared for a letdown i
really enjoy
your insights david uh thank you
thank you i appreciate your support
uh remember if you are watching on
twitch you can
follow me on twitch it's free to follow
and then you'll be notified of my
streams like for example
in three hours i'll be running a chess
tournament uh if you're watching on
youtube make sure to
like the stream and also hit that
subscribe button
um i don't know let me see here
what is going on in terms of subscribers
we are closing in on 880 000 subscribers
on youtube yeah i don't know what's
going on there's been an explosion
lately
we've not done anything different or
special so i really couldn't tell you
what it is that's going on
but i'm i'm certainly not complaining
that's for sure
ally mack says hey david just joined the
stream i saw a recent video from
kyle highlighting 32 percent of
household payments
haven't been made in july this shocked
me have you seen this too yes we
discussed it on the monday bonus show
um wow i'm inconsolable gifting
another 17 subscriptions on twitch that
is
unbelievable that is completely
unbelievable
um a lot is certainly happening there
yeah i discussed that now the housing
payment thing is
32 percent of households did not make
their entire
july 1st housing uh payment doesn't make
it
that much better but it's they didn't
make their entire payment versus they
didn't make any payment at all but we're
headed to a real eviction foreclosure
crisis if things don't get taken care of
and i uh well
i'm gonna save this for for tomorrow but
i sort of let slip on the bonus show
today
that it's occurred to me
whether i might safely relocate myself
for a period of time for coronavirus
safety reasons
let me just say that and a bunch of
people wrote to me saying they want to
hear more about that
and so i'm going to be talking about
that tomorrow on uh
on the broadcast show and i look forward
to
uh to discussing that with you
we have almost 13 000 people watching
on youtube right now this is the biggest
crowd
i've ever had for a single stream on
youtube
i don't know where y'all are coming from
or you guys
as we say here in massachusetts um
but thank you also close to 2 000 folks
watching on twitch nearly 3 000 on
facebook i believe we are right now
uh somewhere in the 16 or 17 000 viewer
range i i'm perple
i'm flummoxed i genuinely have no idea
what's going on we must have hit some
sweet spot in the youtube algorithm or
something like that i don't know
this is crazy um has this frozen no just
jim acosta looks
incredibly still very very still um
okay daniel tesfay says
is it 90 likely that trump loses the
popular vote
yeah i would if i were a betting man and
i'm not i would bet trump loses the
popular vote
matthias germany says i still believe
trump could resign to avoid losing
it's certainly within the realm of
possibility
um people on twitch asking for multiple
resolutions
i have no control over that the way i'm
not a twitch partner i'm only uh
i have a an inferior status with twitch
so it's based on how much bandwidth is
available
um and i have no control over that
comrade dostoyevsky says don't be
surprised so many people are watching
you're a fantastic political analyst and
your content is top-notch
you and kyle are my favorite thank you
so much comrade and i didn't know my mom
had changed her
youtube username to that but i will uh
i'll call you later mom i appreciate the
support
john b says i'm scared to be honest can
we hear you say something in spanish
love the show
oh there's many videos on youtube of me
speaking to viewers in spanish and
um i encourage you to check them out
um we have just breached 14
000 live concurrent viewers on youtube
by far the record let me take if you're
wondering i'm guessing people are just
looking for the press conference
and not only are they not looking for me
they don't like me
and that's okay i'm glad you're here but
if you are just joining on youtube
please hit that like button and the
subscribe button
we these things are free and
i love that you're here and if you want
to do something if you're bored
and you want to do something tonight i'm
running a chess tournament at 8pm
eastern
and it's free to play i'll be playing
i'm terrible but i'll be playing
and you can register at davidpakman.com
slash chess 261 people
currently registered and i i would love
for some of you new viewers
who certainly must be here for the first
time to play in that chess tournament
tonight it would be a fantastic thing
walter aimroid says the only poll
friendly to trump
is putin's pull beautiful well done
thanks to h larson for the super chat
from
norway thanks to ty jones for the
youtube
subscription uh wow 3 000 likes on the
stream that is crazy
that is absolutely wild thanks to that
darn
steve for the twitch prime subscription
steve says
thanks for the insightful coverage david
i started following after the joe rogan
appearance
and i can't help but agree with the
praise you got on youtube
you've got exceptional analysis thank
that's so nice steve you know usually
a lot of my viewers really dislike me um
and it's a great thing to see some
positive comments i really appreciate
that
um let's see here bing says
stimulus money i bet i don't oh maybe
trump is announcing a second stimulus
that's actually interesting i wonder if
donald trump has decided in order to try
to
regain control of this runaway pandemic
and economic situation
and election maybe trump is announcing
that more stimulus checks are coming
that that's a possibility that's a
possibility and we will see uh we will
soon see um trump 16 minutes late now
and uh yeah well i i don't
it seems that there's a lot of movement
uh oh wait a second what's going on now
oh yamiche
alcindor is back and sitting down a lot
of people putting on their jackets
it must be that trump is about to come
out
okay we have surpassed 15 000 live
viewers on youtube we we have set a
record today uh
also there are just so many people
signing up on my website right now that
i can't even keep track of it
uh michael hughes anna lee allen new
worth
rachel klein joe higgins kate
foster niamh bell
avi rifkin a lot of fellow tribe members
signing up love it
melanie ramos lisa stanich i i'm
falling behind but i really appreciate
everybody who's uh signing up i really
do
um yeah we i we this is late trump is
running late everybody
the the male reporters just put on their
suit coats so i assume that trump is
coming out soon
seems to be a big glare here uh i think
our friend
uh weijia jiang here from cbs news she
follows me
she's great uh she is what we call a
friend of the david pakman show
having to use her papers to block the
glare
but it looks like we are getting very
very close
um darren asks pacman for president when
i cannot be president of the united
states i was not born here i am a
naturalized u.s
citizen so much like arnold
schwarzenegger
i am unable to be president of the
united states
at least for the time being uh we have
just
passed 17 000 live concurrent viewers
on youtube this is historic this is
historic
it is an historic day a historic and his
i like anne historic um trump to
announce the jailing of biden
no i'm kidding that's he in his dreams
in his dreams
uh but welcome to all who are just
joining and
i hope that i don't i know a lot of you
at this point it's very clear
a lot of the 20 000 people who are
watching right now are clearly not
looking for me they're looking for the
trump uh
presentation if you can call it that and
to you i say i hope i don't interfere
too much
with you watching what we are about to
see here
um we have a pan happening
is trump coming out
apparently not yet but it looks like the
crowd is
very powerfully ready for donald trump
very very powerfully
sam dean is checking in with a super
chat from australia
g'day mate maybe coincidentally the
pence and louisiana governor edwards
joint news briefing
at tiger stadium in baton rouge is
running two hours late hmm that's
interesting
maybe this is to announce a new stimulus
package
maybe maybe it is uh that is that is
very very interesting
um and if it is maybe they would be
delaying in order for pence to be able
to say
more help is coming sort of thing that's
certainly
a possibility uh we are now
um 20 minutes late and this is normal
for trump i mean he's late all the time
no respect for the press no respect for
the audience whatsoever
um but we will hear something very soon
tanner audia says i was in edgartown
at the same time oh that just scrolled
by where did that go
um where is that
okay i was in edgar town when you were
on martha's vineyard cheers buddy yeah
you can j i was on martha's vineyard
for a very very safe completely safe um
socially distant physically distant
vacation a few weeks ago i broadcast
from there
if if you follow me on instagram
david.pakman
i have a bunch of pictures up from my
trip there
and you can see there's not a soul in
sight not a stolen site but yeah
david.pakman on instagram that's where
those beautiful beautiful pictures are
we um i i may be going i mean listen
i want to do what is safe and what i
read is the safest is
you do a road trip in your own state
that's the safest thing to do right now
and that's exactly what i did there is a
35 minute ferry to get from woods hole
to martha's vineyard
um and it felt reasonable i just sat in
the car the entire time and it was fine
um okay billy vanilli says trump will
announce
kanye as his new running mate can you
imagine
van a dulles says what's going on at the
white house
we're all waiting to see we did reach 20
000 live concurrent viewers on youtube
thank you so much make sure to hit
that like and subscribe button we did
this i don't even know what's happening
we just picked up 400 youtube
subscribers somehow we are now at 879
000 and i'm getting text messages
blowing up
nobody knows what's going on this is
clearly an error i think
youtube meant to promote fox news and
something in the algorithm must have
gotten mixed up and they're promoting me
and furious trumpists are showing up and
they are absolutely
livid with the fact that i showed up in
their recommendations feed i think that
that's what happened
because i can't there's no sensible
reason why i would have twenty one
thousand people watching on youtube
and another two thousand on twitch and
another by the way
thirty one hundred people on facebook is
also a record we i've i've never seen
anything like it
um just as a reminder another
brutal brutal day of coronavirus cases
here in the united states
the day is not over and we are already
at 51 000
new cases florida and florida texas
arizona georgia california leading the
way
as you will notice the only state in the
top
15 that is a blue state is
california deaths ticking up record
deaths in florida
close to a record in arizona arizona did
have somewhere like around 105 or 110.
texas alabama not good let me see how
massachusetts is doing
303 cases that's not great i don't like
that
10 deaths that's good and i think our
curve is still looking pretty good yeah
that's listen i i this isn't i don't i'm
not bragging
i'm grateful to live in massachusetts
right now
given what is going on um in uh
in much of the world it is very bad
california's having to shut down again
it's a disaster in texas it's insane let
me say thanks to a few people who have
just picked up twitch prime
subscriptions public enemy 250
grayson madness 24 johann
or johann jehamin has subscribed
kalio jamlock
quabits once a
faceplant kagers and a lot of other
great people
are signing up on twitch which i very
much appreciate
uh if you're just joining us we are now
approaching
30 minutes late donald trump for
his urgent and abruptly announced press
briefing we have 23 000 people watching
on youtube which is
more than double the most i've ever had
uh if you want to get your message if
you're watching on youtube and you want
to get your message up
in the lower left of the screen that's
called super chat
and um it's a beautiful way to get a
question or a comment to me
sean t says time it's am
in the southern hemisphere um
you know it's not so much about north
south
like in my birth country of argentina
it's an hour later it's 6
30 p.m it's more about
anyway that's not that's for a different
day verum toure
says david can you bring andrew yang on
the show or go on his podcast
so we've continued to invite andrew yang
to be back on
he has not accepted and i'm glad to be
back on
with i'm glad to be on with him anytime
but i have not
had the pleasure of being invited stuart
keating
says who's the hottest idw member
probably eric weinstein right i mean
that guy that that that that guy is uh
something else
now listen i i assume you're asking
since i exclusively date women i assume
you're asking who's the hottest woman in
the idw
i have i couldn't name i don't know
who's in the idw you'd have to give me a
list of people to prick from i have no
idea
thomas powell says uk viewer david this
is a great show
thank you i am compuber says mitch
mcconnell just announced a second
stimulus bill to pass oh
is that true mitch mcconnell second
stimulus
mitch mcconnell open to a second round
of stimulus checks sources say so i've
not i'm not seeing any news that it has
been announced
i'm not seeing that right now um
if i love it if people are pointing out
in the chat
this is not the chess tournament the
chess tournament is tonight at
8 pm eastern i'm hoping for some time to
make some tacos between now and then
but you can register for free at
davidpakman.com
chess that's tonight okay this is
an abruptly scheduled donald trump press
conference
and i'm increasingly wondering if it is
because donald trump is going to
announce
a second stimulus package
and we will soon know unknown prodigy
says hey why no berserk
in the chess tournament you know there's
not too many ways to
encourage higher quality chess um
than to just not allow berserk berserk
is when you can
basically have your time allotted
and you get double the points if you win
i've just
always disabled berserk because it feels
like um
a way to encourage slightly better
chess to be played johnny bishop says
i'm a big fan from the uk keep up the
great work thank you
sweet baby bladefoot says what's the
over under on taking press questions
i actually think today trump will take
press questions
um trump knows that he's on the ropes
and
he thinks he's great at answering
questions of course him answering
questions led to him offhandedly
wondering about injecting bleach and
oprah
isopropyl alcohol into the body to deal
with the virus so
it's a bad idea for him to take
questions he thinks he's great at
answering questions
i think he is likely to take questions
today
g-man says can you do a jojo pose
and sell an autographed picture i have
no idea what that is i hope it's not
racist
um erica and mel signing up
simbarash mashinyare says shout out from
zimbabwe
simba i believe that's the first
zimbabwean super chat that we've had
other folks signing up thomas powell
says
like smash the like button yeah we've
got a
25 000 live concurrent viewers on
youtube
and just a hair short of 5 000
likes unbelievable powerful 2000 on
twitch
um 400 more people just subscribed to
the youtube channel
guys this is nuts we might actually hit
880 000 subscribers
by the end of this stream it's
absolutely crazy i hope some of you will
be here for the chess tournament tonight
william chan says ever play shogi
kind of like a chess cousin i have not
played it
jadakid says thanks to all the miami
cubans who love to vote republican
desantis and trump are your doing
shake my head uh pair tiran
coming in out of nowhere with 500
swedish kroner
says fauci is aaliyah corona is gone
unemployment are at zero percent all of
america loves trump
all african-americans all have well-paid
jobs
china and iran bows to trump blood
throne
so for people who don't know pair tiran
is a swedish viewer i don't know if pair
writes his super chats in english or
he's running them
through some kind of hair brained auto
translate we love
pair pair always puts together these
incredibly ungrammatical super chats
he's a big time supporter a long time
supporter social democracy clearly doing
very very well in sweden
um and we we just i don't know what they
mean it's always like i don't know if
pera is joking or if that's some kind of
strange google
translate rhonda guthrie taft says come
to canada we'll keep you safe love your
commentary and insights
here is donald trump let's see what is
going on
uh the it doesn't look like the white
house
stream is live so we'll go with this
stream let's take a listen here we go
thank you very much everybody please
hope it's not too hot but it's pretty
warm
thank you
so we've had a big day in the stock
market things are coming back and
they're coming back
very rapidly uh-oh a lot sooner than
people thought
people are feeling good about our
country people are feeling
good about uh can everybody therapeutics
and
possible vaccines but we're going to go
over
quite a bit and maybe at the end we'll
take some questions if we have time this
is going to be
not too hot today i signed legislation
and an executive order to hold
china accountable for its oppressive
actions against the people of hong
kong give me a break the hong kong
autonomy act which i signed this
afternoon passed unanimously through
congress
this law gives my administration
powerful new tools to hold responsible
the individuals and the entities
involved in extinguishing hong kong's
freedom
we've all watched what happened not a
good situation
their freedom's been taken away their
rights have been taken away and with it
goes hong kong in my opinion
because it will no longer be able to
compete with free markets
a lot of people will be leaving hong
kong i suspect
and we're going to do a lot more
business because of it because we just
lost one competitor
it's the way it is we lost a very very
serious competitor
a competitor that we incentivized to
take a lot of business and do well
and uh gave them a lot of business by
doing what we did we gave them things
that nobody else had the right to do
and that gave them a big so point one is
a total distraction
it has nothing to do with the crisis of
coronavirus really historic business
tremendous business far bigger than
anybody would have thought years ago
when we
did this uh gift we it was really a gift
to freedom
today i also signed an executive order
ending u.s preferential treatment for
hong kong
hong kong will now be treated the same
as is he really doing this and it's all
about
hong kong like if that if that's the
case that would be insane
export of sensitive technologies
in addition to that as you know we're
placing massive tariffs and have placed
very large tariffs on china the first
time that's ever happened
we're going to switch to the white house
box feed is toxic and that gave them
a big edge over other markets and
because of that edge
they've done really historic business
tremendous business
far bigger than anybody would have
thought years ago when we
did this gift we it was really a gift to
freedom
today i also signed an executive order
ending u.s preferential treatment for
hong kong
hong kong will now be treated the same
as mainland china
no special privileges no special
economic treatment
and no export of sensitive technologies
in addition to that as you know we're
placing massive tariffs and have placed
very large tariffs on china first time
that's ever happened to china
billions of dollars have been paid to
the united states of which i've given
quite a bit to the farmers and ranchers
american businesses pay the tariffs not
china remember that basic econ
that's been going on for three years
first time anybody's ever done anything
like that
and prior to the plague pouring in
from china they were having the worst
years you know in 67 years
and i don't want them to have a bad year
i want them to have a good year but they
were taking advantage of the united
states for many many years
and that's uh stopping
but then the then the virus came in and
uh
the world is a different place but we're
now getting back and
one of the reasons the market's doing so
it's almost at the point that it was at
prior to the plague here we go we're
getting very close
it's a great thing it's an amazing thing
what our people have
done and what they've endured no
administration has been tougher in china
than this
administration we imposed historic
tariffs
we stood up to china's intellectual
property theft this was urgent at a
level that nobody's ever come close
we confronted untrustworthy chinese
technology and telecom providers
we convinced many countries many
countries
and i did this myself for the most part
how crazy is it that only 19 000 people
are watching this on the white house
channel
and 35 000 people are watching it on my
channels
i talked many countries out of using it
if they want to do business with us they
can't use it
just today i believe that uk
announced that they're not going to be
using it
and that was up in the air for a long
time but they've decided and
you look at italy you look at many other
countries we withdrew from the
chinese-dominated
w.h.o and we fully
rebuilt the united states military the
w.h.o
he's going back world health
organization uh
we were paying close to 500 million
dollars a year
china is paying 39 million dollars a
year this can't be why he's doing this
and china had too much say they worked
it very hard
is there some announcement coming bad
thing
done by our past administrations but we
were tough and we were saying i was
asking i said why are we paying so much
more than china
china has 1.4 billion people we have
325 probably 325 million approximately
nobody can give the exact count we're
trying to get an exact count but you
have
over the years many illegals who have
come into the country the guy who
defunded the census wants an exact count
325 to 350 million people as opposed to
1.4
billion people and
the world trade world trade is
terrible that deal is terrible the world
health is a terrible deal
we've been very tough in the world trade
organization and we've been
i guess as tough as you can get on world
health we withdrew our money we told
them we're getting out
doesn't mean that someday we won't go
back in maybe we will when it's
correctly run but they made a lot of bad
predictions and they said a lot of bad
things about
what to do and how to do it and they
turned out to be wrong
and they were really a puppet of china
and make no mistake we hold china fully
responsible for concealing the virus
and unleashing it upon the world it
could have stopped it they should have
stopped it
would have been very easy to do at the
source when it happened
in contrast joe biden's entire career
has been a gift oh my god
to the chinese communist party and to
the calamity
holy [ __ ] of of errors that they've made
they made so many errors
and it's been devastating for the
american worker this is the strategy
china has taken out
hundreds of billions of dollars a year
from our country
and we rebuilt china i give them all the
credit in the world
i don't give the credit for the people
that used to stand here because
they allowed this to happen where
hundreds of billions of dollars were
taken out of the united states
in order to rebuild abrupt press
conference
pandemic raging to attack biden and
obama that's what he's doing that's the
strategy
country in the world has ever ripped off
the united states
like the incredible
job that they did on this country and
the people that ran it
is he slurring now possibly it's one of
the reasons certainly it's one of the
very big reasons trade and things
related to trade that i got elected in
the first place i've been talking about
it for a long time along with
many other subjects frankly joe biden
supported china's entry into the world
trade organization
one of the greatest geopolitical and
economic disasters
in world history if you look at
china you look at the moment they joined
the world trade they were
flatlining for years and years who's
going to change their vote because of
this
and then all of a sudden they joined the
world trade organization
and they went like a rocket ship they
were given all sorts of advantages
they were considered a developing
country as a developing country they
got tremendous advantages over the
united states and other countries
and they took advantage of those
advantages and
and then some they took advantage biden
personally led the effort to give china
permanent most favored nation status
which is a tremendous advantage
for a country to have few countries have
it
but the united states doesn't have it
never did
probably never even asked for it because
they didn't know what they were doing as
vice president biden was
a leading advocate of the paris climate
accord which was
unbelievably expensive to our country
would have crushed american
manufacturers while allowing china
to pollute pollute the atmosphere with
impunity yet one more gift from
his aides must have said you know i
don't know that it makes sense to just
call a press conference abruptly and
attack biden right like someone behind
the scenes must have thought this was a
bad idea of oil we would have had it
close up
uh tremendous amounts of our energy to
qualify eventually not too far into the
future
we would have had to do things that
would have been
unbelievably destructive to our country
including the possible closing of 25
of our businesses think of that and it
was going to cost us hundreds and
hundreds of millions of dollars
for the privilege of being involved in
the paris climate accord i don't think
he knows what he's doing and you just
have to look at what took place
this year in paris and france
where money was being sent to countries
all over the world and
the people of france didn't want to take
it and they didn't and they
did a lot of rioting they had their
taxes raised we would have had to raise
our taxes
and it was a disaster i've been given a
lot of credit for what i did there
took a certain amount of courage i guess
because it sounds so nice the paris
climate accord but it wasn't good for us
at all
no one's giving him credit for getting
out of that other than idiots
everybody's in the paris climate accords
joe biden was vice president think of
that 10
000 factories he wrote
something today and he made a statement
today that i
wrote down pretty accurate
so biden was here for 47 years eight
years the last eight years
not long ago as vice president he said
one in five miles of our highways
are still in poor condition well we're
doing a good job on highways but
why didn't he fix him three years ago
why didn't he fix him
tens of thousands of bridges are in
disrepair
and on the verge of collapse well it's
probably not a right number but
we have bridges that should have been
fixed why didn't he fix him
he was there for eight years with
president obama why didn't they fix them
tens of thousands of bridges this is
what he wrote
high-speed broadband we want high-speed
bird well why didn't he get it
if i were biden i would just sit in the
basement i mean
just let this is a total
self-destruction she's going to be
president as president he's going to do
all the things that he didn't do
he never did never did anything except
make very bad decisions
especially on foreign policy
so joe biden and president obama freely
allowed china to pillage our factories
plunder our communities and steal our
most precious secrets
and i've stopped it largely but i've
stopped it
and it wasn't easy because you talk
about a certain
power of the telephone and the calls
where they would call
and say no we don't want to do that what
is in the countries we call on behalf of
china but i did it
i did what has to be done this feels
like a turning point in some sense
take a look at the kind of at the
numbers where they devalued their
currency in order to pay the tariffs
now the democrat party is calling for
defunding of our military think of that
the funding they want to defund our
military
when china is building a massive
military
they're building a massive military and
biden wants to defund our military
and the world needs american strength
right now more than ever and we've got
it we've
we've got now soon as it
all this equipment comes in all made in
the usa
we've got the newest most incredible
weapons anywhere in the world we have
the best tanks the best
ships the best missiles rockets
we have the best of everything we have
the best fighter jets the f-35
even if you care about the fighter jets
trump has nothing to do with that we'll
have the best fighter jets if biden's
president we had him when obama what the
hell is he talking about
bombers hope we don't have to use them
but we have
the most incredible military when i came
in the military was totally depleted it
was
that's a lie it was at a level that was
just absolutely
incredible you know the statements i
made the statements before i told you
what
generals told me about our military and
nobody can if somebody needs them we'll
give them to you very well documented
as vice president biden opposed
tariffs and he was standing up for china
he didn't want to do anything to disrupt
the relationship with china even though
china was taking us to the cleaners
he opposed my very strict travel ban on
chinese nationals to stop the spread of
the
china virus he was totally against it
xenophobic he called me xenophobic a
month later he admitted i was right
we would have had thousands of people
additionally die if we let people come
in from heavily infected china
this is so stupid that there must be
something
jared kushner's doing right now that's
even dumber than this
that this is meant to distract from
right like what other reason would there
be to do this right now
and others too they all thought what i
did was a terrible mistake we would have
lost
in fact dr fauci said he would have lost
thousands of additional people
if president trump had to do that and i
was a crowd of one
because even experts didn't want to do
it they thought it was a mistake and
then i did
europe when i started seeing what was
going on in italy and
spain and france and other countries in
europe i took action
a ban on people coming in from europe
that would have been
disastrous for our country also
and we saved tens of thousands of lives
but we actually saved millions of lives
by closing
by closing up we saved millions
potentially millions of lives could be
a number that we're actually working on
but it could be
two to three million lives so we're at
135
000. remember it used to be 1 million
when trump was saying it would be 60k
dead it could have been a million maybe
1.5 then it was 1.8 then two
two to two and a half now he's raised
three million as the for the first time
i've heard
now we'll put out the flames as it as it
happens we have to get the schools open
we have to get everything
open a lot of people don't want to do
that for political reasons not for other
reasons
but if we had listened to joe biden
hundreds of thousands of additional
lives would have been lost
and if you look at the job he did on
swine flu i looked at a poll they have
polls on everything nowadays
yeah and uh they got very bad marks on
the march
job they did on the swine flu only 130
000 have died right i mean it's only
like 35 911s
why is everybody so worked up over trump
one got very poor
marks from gallup on the
job they did on swine flu and they
stopped
very early on testing they totally
stopped it
and frankly if we didn't test you
wouldn't have all the headlines because
we're showing cases
here he goes and we have just about the
lowest mortality rate
ninth height if we did think of this
if we didn't do testing instead of
testing over 40 million people
if we did half the testing would have
half the cases if we did another
idiot you cut that in half we'd have yet
again half of that
but the headlines are always testing now
the testing is a good thing but at the
same time
the best way to prevent pregnancy is
don't give a single person a pregnancy
test
no pregnancies 40 million
plus gonna be very close to 45 million
people and when i turn on the news i see
cases cases cases
they don't talk about deaths being cut
down to a level that
actually tenfold they use i got that
from one of the very
respected yeah he doesn't know what it
means and it's not it's wrong also not
tenfold
yes but they don't talk about that uh
they talk about cases and the cases are
created
because of the fact that we do
tremendous testing we're the best
testing in the world
we now make ventilators for the world
very few ventilators
there wasn't one person in any hospital
anywhere in this country
that needed a ventilator that didn't get
it i believe we know of at least
two people where decisions had to be
made like that
act in some cases we mobilized to a
level that nobody thought
possible nothing's happened like that
since world war ii our task force has
done a great job
mike pence worked so hard it gets so
little credit
sad to say that actually because he
worked so hard he had so little credit
the governors would tell us we'd be on
the phone with 50 different governors
that all tell us what a great job
great job and then they'll go to the
media and say well
they didn't do such a good job well we
did a great job we made a lot of
governors look
fantastic we did in new york what we did
in new york was one of the most
incredible things
2 800 bet in javits center but the
governor
used very few of them unfortunately then
we moved in
in the chat please tell me what the
point of this is so to
los angeles and we could have used that
for
our senior citizens we could have used
it for
other people they could have used it
instead of sending our seniors back into
nursing homes that were infected where
you lost thousands of
people thousands of people in new york
died because of poor management
by the governor and it's a very sad
thing to see and
very sad to watch and very sad to look
at those statistics but
we have a we have an incredible javits
center that we built with
thousands of beds i think it's 2 800
all ready to go and they could have sent
people there
or they could have sent senior citizens
there instead of sending them into the
nursing homes
and after all of that work and getting
it done the army corps of engineers
i mean the job they did was incredible
they built it in is this off the cuff
like trump's no longer reading right or
is this notes
fema everybody was there doctors we
ended up getting doctors they said we
can't
man it he said so we'll man it and woman
it
and that's what we did we brought in
doctors nurses everything we're all set
we said where are the people they didn't
send the people
very few people came in they could have
sent them into the javits center they
could have sent them to the hospital
ship which was
virtually unused but we were there
by contrast my administration acted very
early to ban
travel now he's back from china from
europe
saving all of these lives incredible
and i want everyone to know i want every
citizen know that we're using the full
power of the federal government
to fight the china virus and to keep our
people safe
through operation warp speed we will
deliver a vaccine in
record-breaking time we're doing very
well on the vaccines we have many many
different vaccines being studied right
now
many of which are looking really good
please remember the vaccine will have
nothing to do with donald trump and it
may come from a different country
altogether
taking a risk an economic risk of
preparing for delivery because we feel
very certain it's going to be there but
logistically we have
our military ready to go we have
generals that that's all they do is
distribute things and they're going to
be distributed hopefully a vaccine
or a therapeutic and it's coming out
really well
and i think you're going to have some
good news very very quickly having to do
with the vaccines we're also working
with many other countries on the vaccine
many countries are working with us we're
unleashing our nation's scientific
genius to kill the virus
joe biden didn't just side with china
there he is
on the virus he did he called me again
he's like flipping between biden attacks
and rand
like unrelated things it's very weird
does he have the pages of a speech mixed
up
is quote a very positive development not
a positive development not for us it's
not he said that the idea that china is
our competition is really bizarre
he's really bizarre he said china is not
a problem
no nobody's ripped us off more than
china
over the last 25 30 years nobody close
and he says john is not a problem
now he takes it all back now he wants to
be mr tough guy
but for years 47 years he never came out
against china and never said anything
bad just the opposite
his son walked out with 1.5 billion
dollars of
money to invest where he'll make
hundreds of thousands of dollars maybe
millions of dollars a year
walked out with 1.5 billion i asked one
of the biggest people on wall street
maybe the biggest is that possible he
said no
he's never seen it they don't do that
but hunter where's hunter where is
hunter by the way
hunter biden walked out with 1.5 billion
in ukraine he got 83 000 a month and i
guess an upfront payment of 3 million
dollars
so he went from not having a job this is
crazy this is really nuts
83 000 a month with a lot of money paid
up front
to work for erisma
and you all know about barisma nothing
happens nobody cares
and he was unemployed as you know he was
unfortunately forced to leave the
military he was forced to leave
didn't have a job and all of a sudden
he's making a fortune
but nobody talks about that how much
have his kids made off of his presidency
i wonder
more fawning praise about china on an
ordinary
day than about america on the 4th of
july the last independence day biden
attacked the united states and said
we had quote never lived up to the
ideals
of our fathers our forefathers or our
founding fathers
those founding ideals and yet he
enthusiastically stated that
china is a great nation and we should
hope
for its continued expansion well we all
wish well to china but what china's
unleashed on the world
it's uh it's hard to even fathom
i see people now friends of mine they
walk up they want to
say hello and they have to keep their
distance and they're all covered up like
you're all covered up with face masks
it's a different world but we're coming
out on top
biden sides with china over america
time and time again by the way the
number of people getting banned who are
watching the stream for anti-semitic
comments about me right now it's
shocking like what are you doing with
your lives that you just show up and say
anti-semitic things about me it's really
weird but in any case a lot of band
hammers are being dropped
so fast he's so proud of them he's so
proud of them
now joe biden is pushing a platform that
would demolish the u.s economy
totally demolish it so we built the
greatest remember um
stocks do better under democratic
presidents unemployment lower under
democratic presidents inflation lower
under democratic presidents etc etc etc
gdp growth greater under democratic
presidents
just the facts best for african-american
asian-american hispanic-american best
for women
best for everybody best for young people
that didn't have a high school diploma
didn't have a college diploma they had a
diploma they were really in good shape
we built the greatest
ever stock market highest ever in
history we had 143 days of all-time
stock market highs in just
less than three and a half years is this
a campaign rally
we had to close it down because we did
the right thing by doing that as i said
we saved millions of lives
but china was saying this is incredible
what's going on china was for the first
time respecting the united states
and now they want to do something that's
much different joe biden
yeah so i've watched this and i've
watched it with
great interest give us an announcement
building our economy again
policy i guess the stock market went up
almost 500 points today or
something thereabouts you'll check but
it was up a lot when i left
and our economy is coming back we're
almost at a level where
even though it's long before the
twelve percent unemployment very
important maybe the most
important ever election
of november third agreed well long
before that but we're close to record
stock markets again and nasdaq hit an
all-time high for the 16th time
think of that for the 16th time over the
last
month or so for the 16th time so one of
our markets already hit an all-time high
today joe biden gave a speech in which
he said that the core of his economic
agenda is a hard-left
crusade against american energy
he wants to kill american energy he
wants to re-enter
the unfair one-sided paris climate
accord
which will destroy us
at the expense of many other nations who
benefit it was actually drawn in my
opinion
to take advantage of the united states
sure
just like so many other deals are done
to take advantage of the
fools just like many countries are now
taking advantage of the fools that are
running the oval office as we speak
american industry while greatly helping
china
he wants to impose massive energy taxes
and job-crushing mandates to eliminate
carbon
from the united states economy let him
define the word carbon because he won't
be able to
obliterating american oil clean coal
natural gas and the natural energy
resources that supply
supply countless american jobs
joe biden put aoc
a young woman
not talented in many ways
in charge of his energy plan my god
and the environment essentially her and
bernie
sanders yeah who ran a lot of times the
president never made it
good base but that's about it in other
words he wants to impose the green new
deal on
our country when i first saw the green
new deal i thought it was a joke
i said this will never go anywhere now
they're trying to impose it this will
destroy our country
where'd that wall across the entire
southern border and replacing obamacare
with something beautiful go
petition with china and with many other
countries throughout the world we're in
tremendous economic
competition including europe which has
never treated us well
the european union was formed in order
to take advantage of the united states
they formed and they take advantage of
the united states
this is tragic and i know that
they know i know that but other
presidents had no idea
right last week joe biden released his
unity platform developed with
socialist bernie sanders describing what
he would do if
elected president the biden sanders
agenda
agenda is the most extreme platform of
any major party nominee
by far in american history i think it's
worse than
actually bernie's platform it's gone so
far right
and he's doing that because he's begging
for that vote well what's true is that
if elected biden would actually have the
most progressive platform of any
president in the modern era
biden's policy is certainly to the left
of obama's
a couple of weeks and these are actual
key elements of the biden sanders unity
platform
abolish immigration detention no more
detention you come in here illegally
no more detention stop all deportation
so if we get a
ms-13 gang member which we've taken out
of our country by the thousands
brought them back to honduras guatemala
can't do that anymore el salvador
can't do that anymore stop all
deportations others will take
all of these people many of whom are in
prison
for rape murder
lots of other things wait they're
already in prison and prosecution of
illegal border crosses oh okay they come
in illegally and we have to stop the
whole process
support the deadly sanctuary cities
where
many of these people are protected
better than the american citizens
are they in prison are they in sanctuary
cities
are they out on the street in gangs are
they look
which people is he talking about that's
exactly what they do
incentivize illegal alien child
smuggling they're incentivized by what
this plan calls is he high right now
expand asylum
for all new illegal aliens how about
that one
all new illegal aliens expand asylum
cancel all asylum cooperation agreements
in the western hemisphere well we have
agreements with honduras
guatemala this can't be real
yes great agreements where when
biden and obama used to bring killers
out
they would say don't bring them back to
our country we don't want them well we
have to we don't want them they wouldn't
take them now with us they take them
someday i'll tell you why someday i'll
tell you why
but they take them and they take them
very gladly they used to bring them out
and they wouldn't even let the airplanes
land if they brought them back by
airplanes they wouldn't let the buses
into their
country they said we don't want them
he said no but they entered our country
illegally and they're murderers
they're killers in some cases and they
said nope we don't want them
they turn the bus around they turn the
plane around then they'd land in the
united states and who knows what
happened to him
but it wasn't good taxpayer-funded
lawyers
will be given to all illegal aliens so
we're going to pay now for
i mean listen do we have due process or
don't we that doesn't seem controversial
legal aliens
taxpayer-funded lawyers how does that
sound pretty good
in other words come in here illegally
we're going to give you free legal
advice
we'll take you up to the supreme court
as much as possible
abolish immigration enforcement against
illegal workers think of that abolish
immigration enforcement you've got to
enforce it against the companies really
if nobody hired them they wouldn't be
coming here and of course we're
dependent on them actually being here
and working
down the wall they're taking it down
they want to take down the wall
which we fought hard for up to 259 miles
right now of great powerful wall
that's really working because if you
look at the numbers in addition to the
fact that mexico
for various reasons has 27 000 soldiers
on our southern border
to keep people out of our country and i
appreciate it we had a great meeting i'm
getting what sap messages from my family
in argentina they're watching the stream
they don't understand how this is
something that's happening in the
country like how
how how did trump get here today and to
deliver this speech how is this possible
but he's a great guy and he's a friend
of mine and they've been
terrific mexico has been terrific 27 000
soldiers
on our border mexican soldiers and
we have great great numbers
uh we get rid of so many different
things
catch and release is gone so many
different things
have taken place we used to catch them
take their name
and release them into our country we
don't do that anymore
okay we now release them back where they
came from sometimes we'll bring them
back to their country
grant work permits for illegal aliens so
if you come in illegally get a work
permit
people that live here don't get work
permits many cases
provide taxpayer subsidies and welfare
for
illegal aliens and new immigrants so we
want to provide
taxpayer subsidies and welfare
for people that come into our country
illegally illegal immigrants
they want government health care for all
illegal
aliens this is part of their plan i'm
not making this up this is all down in
their plan
from last week
and this is good compared to what i
heard today
federal student aid and free community
college for illegal aliens what do you
think about that
federal student aid and free community
college
we're going to have every person in the
world
pouring into our country from all over
the world and by the way the wall was so
timely because it stopped people coming
in from heavily infected areas
of mexico if we this has been going on
for 34 minutes
it feels like it's been going on for
hours you wouldn't believe and
remember cases is different than deaths
and cases we give you because our
testing is the best in the world
and by the way by far the most 45
million find out
which country tested 45 million people
if china if we're 23rd in testing per
capita just a reminder fact check
five million people or if they did tests
like we did
check out how many cases they'd have but
it's still
we've done a great job get no credit for
it and i don't want the credit i want
the people that have done this great job
the people that have done such an
incredible job on building the
ventilators and
doing the testing and building a testing
platform that's been amazing we have
many platforms many companies have come
up with different forms of tests
when we started there was no such thing
sign new immigrants up for welfare
immediately this is joe biden
so they walk off and they come in and
they put a foot into our
land and we sign up new immigrants no
i've not reviewed
i i would not even assume that trump is
telling the truth
for the the first thing before i do
anything would be i would want to see
the plan for myself
prince think of that sign up it's hard
to believe i'm even
reading that new immigrants for welfare
immediately not to mention the cost
of this which is incalculable
the cost of this is so crazy end
requirement
for immigrant self-sufficiency and
maximize
their welfare now this is us writing
this
who's not coming to the united states
every person
from south america is going to pour in
every person from
this is a common thing republicans think
everybody's desperate to live in the
united states and of course that's
really not the truth
immigrant self-sufficiency and
remember to maximize welfare so we give
it a maximum
then we have massively expand
immigration during a global pandemic
taking jobs from unemployed americans
into all travel bans including from
jihadist regions
so now we have travel bans
a lot of you said i didn't get the
travel ban and you were wrong
we got the travel ban we lost in the
ninth circuit we lost again in the ninth
circuit
and then we won on the supreme court we
have a very strong travel ban
and we don't want people that are going
to come in and
blow up our cities do things
and frankly with the with the liberal
democrats running the cities
yeah when's the announcement happening
here like what was the point of this
press conference
mind but i would mind and the people of
this country mind
so listen to this end all travel bans
he's talking about the band that i won
that everybody said i didn't win they
said i didn't win because in the lower
court we lost that we lost in
the appellate division and then we won
in the supreme court crystal clear
he lost got it and they're right at the
lower level but in the meantime we
wanted the supreme court
so it's in effect but they didn't say
that they said he lost which again is
fake news
that's the way they do it so and all
travel bans including from
jihadist regions they specify that
grant mass amnesty
everybody gets amnesty mass amnesty
think of that
and this is create a road map to
citizenship the way this is going we
should be lucky if he doesn't start
throwing feces around before the
care of daca much better than the
democrats did
the democrats had their chance and they
blew it
but we're going to take care of daca
because i'm going to be doing
in the not too distant future pretty
soon i'm going to be signing a new
immigration action very very
big merit-based immigration action
that based on the daca decision i'll be
able to do
vastly expand low-skilled immigration to
the united states
so they want a lot of people come in
with low skills i like merit
think of that vastly expand low-skilled
immigration to the united states these
are the things that are in the plan
this is biden biden's gone radical left
increased refugee admissions by
seven hundred percent huh
that's a lot 700 nobody's ever heard of
such a thing
increase refugee admissions by 700
percent
abolish law enforcement as we know it
i think the police do an incredible job
in this country
please aren't going anywhere and you're
going to have a rogue terrible cop
on occasion like you do in any industry
in any business this might help biden a
lot of people aren't thrilled with biden
because they think he's too centrist
trump's making him out to be some
radical leftist end
cash bail no bail just we let you right
out
look at what's happened to new york
crime is up shootings are up
at numbers that nobody's ever seen
before look at chicago what a disaster
understand that the police haven't been
abolished yet so obviously crime is not
up for that reason
the reason crime is up is people are
desperate economically because of what's
going on i'm sure most of you all know
that
we have everybody ready to go we have
the national guard
they're all ready to go right cash bail
hasn't been ended you can't blame that
for what's going on now
onto our streets cash bail new york just
did that
other places have done it they haven't
turned out too
good abolish
completely the death penalty great idea
and i know there's a lot of debate on
the death penalty and there has been for
a long time but
sometimes you use the death penalty
oh depending on the crime yes i didn't
think about what happened today with
regard to the death penalty
appoint social justice prosecutors
in order to free violent criminals
so they want to appoint social justice
prosecutors
to free violent criminals and
mandatory minimums
and that's by empowering judges to
determine appropriate sentences
by fighting to repeal mandatory minimums
at the federal level and give states
incentives
to repeal their mandatory minimums
we could go on for days please don't
incentivize
prison closure so they want to close our
prisons they now
want to abolish they want to abolish our
well part of the reason we have so many
people in prison is we have so many
prisons to fill which
maintains jobs etc so yes if you
restructure the war on drugs you
actually would reduce the need for
prisons and yeah
some correctional officers wouldn't be
needed those communities
so they want to close them
rather than have them for some very bad
people people that are not going to
behave when they get out you see that in
new york they
allowed a lot of criminals out and those
criminals are
causing havoc and then they got rid of
their incredible and legendary
crime squad and
things are happening in new york bad
things are happening
i love new york i hate to see what's
going on all right we'll get to
end solitary confinement
sounds good free federal housing for
former inmates so federal housing now
can go to
you know what's crazy about this is like
i don't know how much of this stuff is
really in biden's
thing i'll i'm gonna look at it i assume
it's not worded this way
but this is like if you look at a trump
white house budget it's just a political
document
none of the stuff is even actually going
to be run through legislation
if you were to go by that then you know
the the
the white house budget would be a
ludicrous document this is not very
useful to figure out who you should vote
for
homes offices and all new buildings by
2030
that basically means no windows no
nothing
what it's very hard to do i tell people
when they want to go into some of these
buildings how are your eyes because they
won't be good in five years
and i hope you don't mind cold office
space in the winter and warm office
space in the summer
no ac no heat no windows
no lighting no water it just it's an
empty space
from power plants by 2035 zero
we're talking about zero nothing can go
in the air
mandate net zero carbon emissions by
2015. that's a great goal
and i believe he's changing that he's
bringing it down he wants no petroleum
product he wants no oil or gas i don't
think texas is going to do too well
they're going to get rid of about
7 million jobs guys if half of this
stuff is true
i'm much more excited to vote for biden
homer
north dakota pennsylvania you're going
to be too happy with that
and many other states ohio mandate all
500
000 school buses and all three million
government vehicles be
changed to zero emission vehicles with
you to five years you should still work
we should set the example install 500
000 taxpayer funded charging stations
nationwide
love it here's a bad one really bad one
end school choice there is school
choices
code for take money from public schools
to give to charter schools to make
public schools even worse
to say see we were right they're
terrible to take more money from them
rinse repeat repeat repeat happy
to see him be defeated just on that
alone
and school choice so joe joe biden wants
to end
school choice and tax credit scholarship
serving disadvantaged students in 26
states
oppose 14 million americans with
education
savings accounts and get rid of school
choice having to do with school choice
eliminate
school choice in washington d.c you know
what they've done in washington they
have some
incredible example right here example
i know of one example i think they have
a number of them but one is incredible
abolish all charter schools
charter schools are doing great
ban funding for charter schools in poor
neighborhoods we don't want
charter schools in poor neighborhoods
well that's not fair
abolish educational standards
abolished in the suburbs you're going to
abolish the subreddits with this enforce
obama biden's radical a f f
h that's the a f f regulation
he has no clear reasons to strip locally
no idea what he's doing
a federal affordable housing funds
unless they
change their zoning laws it seems to be
sundowning i think they've got to pull
him off the stage
i've been watching this for years in
westchester coming from new york
they want low-income housing built in a
neighborhood well i'm ending that rule
i'm taking it out
so no neighborhood i spoke with ben
carson the other day
we're going to be taking it out brain
surgeons in charge of housing smart
whole thing go and now they want to make
it
twice as bad in the suburbs in the
suburbs
mothers aren't happy about that fathers
aren't happy about that
they worked hard to buy a house and now
they're going to watch the housing
values drop
like a rock and that has happened drop
like a rock
so we're not going to do that we're
going to do the exact opposite
probably there has never been a time and
this is just a few
this is it's much worse than that we did
this very quickly
it's probably never been a time when
candidates are so different
who do you think proposed this did trump
come up with the idea of doing this for
an hour himself or did someone propose
it
to come in through merit through a legal
process they don't want to have any
borders at all they're going to rip down
the wall
it was hard to get that built and now
it's
almost completed it'll be completed by a
little after the
end of the year they want to rip it down
and it's had such an impact it's
incredible it stops traffic in human
trafficking of women
and children but women mostly human
trafficking one of the worst things ever
all
at a level that it's never been at
because of the internet you wouldn't
think you think of it as an
ancient statement you wouldn't think
that's possible trump's barely treading
water right now and nobody's throwing
him a life raft
and they want to let that gun
continue the the wall has stopped it so
much because they will go over to a
section where there aren't
people not an entry point right and
they'll make a left into the united
states
they're on their way they can't do that
anymore we have a 30-foot
this is a great opportunity to let you
know you should really read the book
coyotes by ted conover who i recently
interviewed he actually
he's an american white guy but he spent
time crossing the border with coyotes
working at uh citrus farms potato farms
etc with undocumented workers it's a
fantastic book could not recommend it
more highly
think of open borders today though with
the pandemic
i mean the timing is sort of interesting
but with the pandemic
so there's never been a time when two
candidates
were so different i mean i've seen
races where it's like ted's
exact platforms i'm even talking about
essentially democrat republican there's
not that much difference there's a
little difference but there's not
much you choose one because you like the
way they look
you like the way they sound you like the
way they talk
you like something about one and you
don't like the other but there's you
know there's never been
a difference here's one of the greatest
different this is without question the
single biggest difference if you want
law and order
for instance i enacted recently when i
saw that was going on with
federal monuments we don't have the
right to do states although we're going
to
we're trying to find it but check out my
clip from from today i don't wait uh yes
today
about we can't allow them to turn this
into a culture war
because they've lost on policy so
talking about statues and flags and
monuments is all he has
an act that we've used and we have many
many people in jail right now
many many people in jail all over the
country
because they tried to destroy or in some
cases got
got it down a federal statute or
monument we haven't had anybody making a
move since i
enacted this i signed an executive order
a couple of weeks ago
and it says very simply 10 years in jail
you do it
10 years in jail the amazing part is
we're able to catch
everybody because thanks to all of you
on television we appreciate it
but we have their pictures we have the
man standing on
andrew jackson's horse is this a medical
event that's happening right now
general george washington we have
everybody
standing in a they were going to go for
the emancipation proclamation
abraham lincoln standing
with the young man who was being freed
and we said
we're going to do something we can't let
this happen now it could be
removed at some point just to catch you
up don't worry you're not missing
anything trust me
the white house abruptly scheduled a
press conference
which presumably was to announce
something important
and trump has been rambling for close to
an hour right now including just reading
negative things about joe biden many of
which are untrue although
the ones that are true are actually
encouraging me more to vote for joe
biden
to see that the next night
i believe 22 people showed up they said
we're going to make it friday night
instead
and 22 people showed up four were
actually arrested because we have
pictures of them knocking down
other statues so they're in jail now
so there has never been an election
where we've had this kind of difference
we want strong borders without borders
you've heard me say it a thousand times
without borders you don't have a country
right they don't want to have borders
they want to have open borders
that's why it's radical left nobody
wants that and it'll destroy
everybody in power one 20 years ago
venezuela was a very
rich country has nothing to do with the
richest
one of the richest and as well as a
disaster capitalist nothing to do with
tremendous oil reserves now they don't
have water
they don't have food they don't have
medicine we do everything we can to take
care of the people
biden versus trump has nothing to do
with venezuela exactly
the ideology that you have going over
here
if i wasn't there to stop it maduro
biden
i don't know that there's anything in
common it's not gonna happen
we'd be in some mess we'd be in some
mess
and pelosi and schumer and
bernie and joe
they'll never stop it they don't have
the power the strength to stop it it's
beyond them
but we do so there's never been a time
like this
you keep saying that where you've had an
election of people
so different okay a couple of questions
yep please my
sir you god spent the better part of an
hour explaining why americans should
choose you and not your opponent
yesterday you said on twitter be careful
what you wish for i guess the question
is do you see yourself as the underdog
in this race do you see yourself
losing in the fall no i don't i think we
have really good poll numbers
they're not suppression polls they're
real polls why you look at the uh
intercoastal in florida you look at the
lakes you see thousands of boats
there's a particular lake in central
florida where all the
boat owners love trump and all over you
look at what's going on you look at
bikers
for miles and miles riding up highways
proudly with their signs
right i have look we won a race
where it was the same thing 2016. we
know in martha's vineyard i did see one
boat with a trump flag
so it's true he might be right be fake
not all couple of them got it right
three of them to be exact three of them
one of them was unsuspecting
but they got it right they were very
proud of it
but uh we had in 2016
uh something even more so but
we got in and we had 306 to
i guess 223 which was a tremendous
margin of difference you remember they
all said he cannot get to 270.
i went to maine a number of times where
we just freed up
lobster fishing and fishing yes the
lobster thing is hilarious
the idea that trump rescued lobster
fishing from obama destroy i mean it's
just
it's crazy you know european union which
charge our fishermen tariffs
yeah lobsters and they said you're not
going to do that so we freed it up for
maine
question was are you going to take a
look we went up there recently there
were crowds thousands of people lined up
going over to a factory where we were
opening up for
we're making swabs a beautiful big new
factory making swaps
i think that the enthusiasm now
is greater and maybe far greater than it
was in 2016.
go on i think a lot of people don't want
to talk about it i think they're not
going to
say hey i'm for trump i'm for trump they
don't want to go through the process
because the process is not fair the
media doesn't treat us fairly
they never have and perhaps they never
will but maybe they will when we turn
this around for a second time i feel bad
for trump he's such a victim
when we turn it around for a second time
everybody hates him
i think we're doing very well in the
polls
and i think you have a silent majority
the likes of which this country has
never seen before
this is a very important election we've
done a great job
we had to turn it off as i said turn it
off and now we've started it
remember trump never turned anything off
it was governors who said hey we've got
to do something here
people and that beat the last month
which was also a record 2.8 million
people nobody's ever done what we've
done
and now we're doing it twice and i think
by election day you're going to see some
incredible numbers the third quarter is
going to be really good
yeah fourth quarter is going to be great
but next year is going to be one of the
best economic
years so hopefully i'll be able to uh
be the president where we say look at
the great job i did
my god at this point i think great i
think we have a great chance i think
we're gonna have a lot of people show up
i'm very worried about mail-in voting
because i think it's
trump thinks absentee voting and mail-in
voting are two different things i've got
a story about it tomorrow it's so funny
i believe it was 20 percent of the vote
was fraudulent it was
fraudulent all sorts of things happen i
understand a
a mailman was recently indicted
someplace for
playing trying to help the mail in
ballots remember if he got indicted the
system worked it's like saying we
shouldn't build houses because sometimes
smoke detectors detect fire
no no no you have the smoke detector so
that you can safely build a house
since you have to go through a process
if i'm here and i vote in florida
you get an absentee ballot but you have
to go through a process absentee ballot
same thing yeah see but man he doesn't
realize we're talking about the same
thing
millions of ballots to people all over
the state
california millions and millions of
ballots doesn't exist and then they come
back they don't come back who got them
did you forget to send them to a
republican area or a democrat area i
guess you could say
but if you take a look at all of the
unbelievable
fraud that's been involved with mail-in
voting over the last even
short period of while but look at
paterson new jersey
it was a massive error and a massive
miscalculation and there was
incredible fraud look at the city
council what's happened to it
this is one place but you have many
places
and they're all over yes please
thank you sir i wanted to know when's
the last time you spoke with
president g of china and do you plan to
speak with him in the near future
no i haven't spoken to him one no i
don't i have no plan to speak to him
ruth bader ginsburg was hospitalized
today with an infection wanted to know
if you had any reaction to that
no i i wish you're the best i hope she's
better i didn't hear that actually
she was just hospitalized no that's too
bad no i wish you're the best
she's actually giving me some good
rulings
okay so then she's okay i got it people
were surprised no
i wish you the absolute best please
thank you mr president so you were
mentioned the travel bans
and i wonder when do you plan to review
that because the european countries are
you know the situation is under control
much a better place than the us
yes and there is no ban for other hot
spots like russia and india
so what would be the criteria to change
that you know another question you know
we've banned for europe
and at some point that'll come off and
we're dealing with them all the time the
relationship's very good they just
don't treat us very well from every
trade uh they are
they have been very unfair to us over
many many decades
and we're doing that it's very easy to
solve i was all set to solve it actually
and then we got hit with the
the plague but uh we have a travel ban
on various countries and that travel ban
remains until such time as we say it
doesn't rebound
and we want our country safe right we
don't
unlike biden we don't want to have
criminals pouring into our country
right we don't want to have open borders
we're not going to have that
and we want to take care of our police
we want to actually
fund our police not defund that question
we're not going to abolish our police
and we're not going to make our military
small and weak
because probably or at least at top of
the level
we need our military right now yeah go
ahead please listen so
how do you think that the america first
policy can work
during a pandemic aren't you concerned
that this could actually damage the us
and make china more influence around the
world okay
look my policy is america first we've
lost
hundreds of billions of dollars a year
with china and many other countries
and what we're doing is just handing
everybody everything it's just
sad i've watched it i've looked at it we
did the u.s mexico you saw that usmca
we made a very fair deal on trade we had
the worst deal ever
right you know that we had the worst
deal ever and it replaced
that it replaced that horrible nafta
deal that was
one of the worst trade deals ever made
i'll tell you the only deal that might
be worse is the
the world trade w.t.o maybe where's uh
oan please president um
your administration has taken tangible
steps to
ensure that chinese companies are not
taking advantage of
our u.s stock markets our trade um
last week your administration sent a
letter to the railroad retirement board
alar asking them to reconsider and she
doesn't even understand her own
questions it's crazy
meaning not to invest correct so uh
where is that request now and are you
taking tangible actions to ensure that
u.s
investments don't continue to fund
defense firms in china you'll see more
coming this was a very important
bill that we signed but you're going to
see more coming uh over the next short
period of time but yes
you don't want them investing in chinese
military companies
okay letters i mean what actions can be
taken to ensure that does not happen
well you have a lot of actions we can
take including the uh
including the increase you know right
now people don't know china's paying a
lot of tasks we made a china deal
yeah and they bought just i think
american companies pay the tariffs when
they import the chinese stuff
it's i mean can somebody just explain
how tariffs work to trump can anybody do
it
it's great for our farmers but i view it
differently than i did before i made the
deal
when i made the deal i thought this was
a great deal after
what happened to us what happened to the
world
coming from china i view it much
differently but we can impose
massive tariffs on china if we want and
other countries if we want
and we'll see we just want to be treated
fairly we want a level playing field our
farmers were never treated properly by
anybody
and they were targeted by china you know
i paid our farmers 28 billion dollars
over a two-year period
sure because they were targeted to that
amount of money today that's a certain
amount of money 28.
it was 16 billion and it was 12 billion
28 over a two year period and we gave 28
billion dollars to our farmers that's
why they're all
here and now they're doing very well our
farmers are doing very well because we
made really great trade deals usmca just
kicked in
the china deal they're buying a lot they
are buying a lot we'll say that they're
buying a lot
a lot of people ask how are they doing
on the trade deal they're buying a lot
so i want to thank everybody and we'll
be having these conferences again i
we're going to be signing an immigration
unbelievable act very soon it's going to
be uh based on merit
it's going to be very strong truly we're
going to work on daca because we want to
make people happy and i'll tell you even
conservative republicans want to see
something happen with daca the
democrats had their chance for three
years to do something with daca and they
always turned it down
they always turned it down they used it
he deserves to be voted out merely for
abruptly and urgently scheduling this
and then ranting for over an hour and
then taking three questions
it'll be great it'll be merit-based the
country's tried to get it for
25 or 30 years it'll be strong on the
border but you'll come in legally and
you'll be able to come in legally
and very importantly we'll be taking
care of
people from daca in a very republican
way republicans i've spoken to many
republicans and some would like to leave
it out but
really they understand that it's the
right thing to do so we're going to be
taking care of daca we will be doing
for daca what the democrats had a chance
to do and they never did it okay
thank you all very much this
has to be the beginning of a
whoa fouchy out of nowhere um this has
to the beginning be the beginning
of a complete and total unraveling that
is time none of us will ever get back
we did at one point during that have
more than 40 000 different people
watching the stream across all of our
different platforms
and i i i'm glad and feel flattered that
you chose to spend the last hour and a
half with me
but that was absolutely insane
from the standpoint of being informative
nothing of substance informed so listen
here's what we're going to do
um if you're watching on twitch remember
to hit that follow button
if you're watching on youtube remember
to hit that subscribe button it's
completely and totally free
i mean it just it costs you nothing i'm
going to be back in about an hour
because we do have a chess tournament
tonight you can subscribe register for
free at davidpakman.com
chess i'll be coming back in about an
hour gonna make some tacos you know get
that all going
um and then we're gonna have that
tournament happening tonight and i
invite you to join me but at minimum
at minimum please hit that subscribe and
follow button it is much appreciated and
if nothing else in about an hour
you can watch me fail miserably in my
own chess
tournament thanks for joining me guys i
do appreciate it
you